welcome to this video playing Duane
Duane yeah someone explain to me to
Wayne how to pronounce that been
probably feeling battling okay so animos
oh um okay let's play something else not
the same ish again okay going back to e7
and ok probably night g3 is the right
the right way to play t5 I don't know
cd5 bishop f1 or queen f3 something like
that ah I'm not sure this is certainly a
theoretical position but I am I don't
know the details my idea was that night
f5 might be might be nice yawn how to go
about this now maybe Queen f3m intending
97-95 winning a Paul and I move like c6
would be a young quite a substantial
concession ok so this what about g4g 45
is this completely wacky yeah not
completely but
h4 h5 maybe this is interesting h4 h5
trying to keep the night on f5 in case
of g six so h5 is the idea my play 94-94
i can i can just take h5 is not strictly
an attacking it's mostly designed to
keep this night on a five and diner five
it is so it is an annoying piece and
then h4 h5 also make sure that the rook
has some role in this game after Eiffel
fated castling rights this makes some
sense at least I hope it makes some
sense ok yeah that's the counter play
very understandable ok if he takes I
have night takes so this is not a big
big issue
yep now there's some pressure on deform
interesting GG 595 probably that's
probably I'm okay for black okay I need
some protection of deform this exchange
at least them opened up my bishop on d
to maybe am he's going for 94 now this
is at least and the move I would
strongly consider here yeah I think this
is a good move okay if I take hear ya de
force the problem and the spawn is just
just hanging
we'll give six is a threat okay 95 I
have queen d 5 yeah it's a bit of a
fakie position no doubt about that
that's hot Queen at five here taking d5
I have some doubts about my position
here but it's still interesting yeah
Bishop takes a three would be an
amazingly if greedy move maybe you can
play that okay so capturing and queen
age three if there should be four
actually the H takes g6 Queen Queen here
Bishop g7 and then Bishop to b4 this is
so very annoying from like keeping
threatening Queen h7 made
I should have given the check first of
course this would have been would have
been stronger a stupid stupid stupid no
after the temperature here he can he can
continue
I have this just the other move and it's
over completely over hmm yeah yeah now
the tables are turned it just has f7 for
the king
yeah just chillin the check first simply
would have won the game with no big
problems
check
check
yeah this is um okay now it's about
equal yeah he's something slightly
better of course I mean I'm
contradicting myself here and what I'm
what I'm saying is that black has a
symbolic advantage because of this
default born but it's it's nothing that
you can win a game with normally
check draw time warning yep again such a
silly game well let's know nothing to do
yeah now now this absolutely zero chance
for anything but of course is not the
broad chess anymore black4 fits on time
yeah that's what you get if you play on
time at least once in a while yeah of
course it was completely dead
disposition here it's just adjusted that
draw where you cannot do anything he's
got the slightly better of it because
I've got this pawn on d4 but I never
never able to win this and at the end it
was just this typical scramble with no
relation any way to to chess um yeah but
I'm really a bit a bit sick that I
didn't play play Queen age 7 here
I forgot about Queen takes f6 really
here I just thought okay f5 I take but
Queen f6 keeps the rock protected I
forgot that this is this as possible
protecting the rook and I can instead of
that I can just give the check first and
then just end and it's just gone he's
got no moose got a group d 6 but this is
this is not not working at well or is
this something but I even I know yes
that is completely enough this just
drops the bishop so check here and then
getting getting this exchange I can't
even try to improve first immunity start
even able to get out of the spin nicely
yeah okay well thanks for watching